AND
>> WOW.
SUGGS.
THIS IS A PACE I CAN GET BEHIND
TEAMMATE OF CREATIVITY IS HE
VOTES.
>> OR TWEET
NO, HE'S NOT.
>>> THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO
THROW IT BACK.
>> HE LOOKED BACK.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING CRAZY.
HE'S GOT 17 OF HIS TEAM'S 38 IN
CONTIERRASANTA THEY PLAY
DEFENSE.
>> YOU KNO WORTHY, THEY MADE A
FURIOUS COME
WE CAN'T KEEP GOING THE ISIAH.
HE'S NOT 48-46 A.
JAMES WORTHY COMES BACK TO GO TO
>> HE DOES A FLIP, AND HE M ON
THEIR FEET.
>> CAN'T FOUL.
>> GREEN GETS A
AND DESMOND BANE, WITH ICET'S W
AGAINST PHOENIX IN 28 L.
BATTLES WITH SENGUN.
ROLLS IT TO
THEY ARE NOT MESSING AROUND OUT
CONDITION.
LINES UP. TO GET THAT ONE
TO FALLCUNNINGHAM.
IT'S STARTING TO GET REAL RUNNI
AT THE REF.
COULD HAVE USED A  WAY.
AN ENJOYING OW THESE
PLAYERS ARE PHE WANTED THE WIN.
TEAM BARRY CAN WIN IT MOBLEY.
18 SECONDS ON THE SHOT
THE SHOT CLOCK.
11 SECONDS.
>> PLAY.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT PLAY HE IS
>> LAMELO.
TATE RECOVERS.
GOES TO THE LANE, AND GETS IT TO
FALL!HIM.
SHOT CLOCK.
>> HE GOT SHOTS.
YOU WEREN'T EXPECT ANYTHING LESS
FROM RICK LOT OF
MINUTES IN THIS LEAGUE.
>> BEHIND YOU, BEHIND YOU.
>> THAT VOICEEAKING WAGNER TO T
BASKET.
>> HIS TEAMMATES
>> THAT IS A GREAT IT TO GO.
COUNTRY CONDITION GOING THE DIDR
PLANS.
WE LAST
NON-G LEAGUE PLAYER THIS GAME A
THIS GAME HERE.WAY.
CUNNINGHAM, DRIVES, HERE,
IN THE BASKETBALL DOWN.
SEE WHO COMES THROUGH DOWN THET.
COME UP BIG IN THE CLUTCH AGAIN.
WE ARE GOING THE OTHER WAY. WAG.
BEY IS GOING BETWEENO HERE.
>> CUNNINGHAM.
>> I AM A TOP PICK FOR A REASON.
S
THE CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> WE ARE OUT OF HERE.